at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
hey everybody it's Wednesday things look
a little bit brighter than normal uh no
I mean because of this I think I'm gonna
turn it down like I think it looks good
though you think yeah yeah it looks good
I know what it is what's that you got
the blue wig on and you got the pale
skin and it you're reflecting more light
don't jump it yeah I'm blind again
you got that [__] honky ice princess
look on you today right like some of a
Star Trek
she's looking attractive I'm walking in
and she's wearing this little short
[__] baby doll dress she's got the
the hair and the boobs and I'm just man
and she's like why you always wait till
the show I can't control it I can't
control it so like I'm sitting here
trying to like do a last minute read on
my desk they're very visual we are
visual creatures you didn't look like
that when you came when you came home
but this should just start looking like
a slime yeah if you look like a store
then all the views good
we used to get a [__] ton of views when
all the [__]
thumbnails for the show were just Jenny
with cleavage we'd get a [__] out of
them I actually had fun I didn't make it
you had some of it like that [__] and
then like uh because some of our long
time listeners [__]
two of them said yeah really I started
watching it because Jenny had a [__]
nice rack man [__] but you guys are
really cool she's really smart you know
but no that was a great selling point
back in the early days
man I did so much [__] today [__]
cooked worked in a garden [__] uh
went to [__] Starbucks for [__]
two three hours to chill out up the road
the clothes would here oh yeah you went
to that one yeah not the far away one
yeah this is this is the amateur one the
professional ones over there I've never
been to this one up here one of these
days it's small well but I go in there
and I stick out like a sore [__]
thumb I love it yeah I [__] love it
yeah you're like what the [__]
but the uh okay where's the we like to
be the weirdos we are we are the weirdos
Mister yeah pull a [__] bike up and
should come out they're like oh [__] man
it's all people not trying to look at me
and [__]
all right it's okay people he's like I
might not kill you I've committed enough
robberies for today
and murder yeah it's gonna be all right
your daughters will all be safe
[Laughter]
yeah here okay now here we are all right
yeah Trey said Tom's right Jenny's much
brighter today yeah I was fighting
around with the light and also like one
of the lights that's behind the laptop
like I have something on top of it and
it for some reason when I touched it it
changed colors because yeah okay
um because that's how it does I guess so
it might be that doesn't really like
affect too much over there like that
like but it does kind of bounce off so
yeah I don't know I couldn't decide if I
liked it and then I was like [__] it I'm
going with it yeah see Trey says Tom's
right Jenny's much brighter today that's
what I just said yeah
Trey also said I love this topic I had
several of those Scholastic stranger
Mysteries books yeah so did I uh that
you get at school Book Fairs that
covered this story uh yeah this is um
this is a great story and honestly I
don't know I know we did a ghost ships
show before like a long time ago and I
remember that we covered I know we
talked about the what do you call it the
orang Medan which is actually not real
it's just like a fictional story that
got completed into a real one and I
think we talked about the MB joyita uh
the what is what's that one called the
bachinko or whatever that one's called
the one that floated around for like 50
years or whatever we talked about that
one but that was a real one wouldn't it
yeah yeah yeah
um orang Madan is the only one that's
not real yeah but um I don't remember if
we covered the Mary Celeste on there I'm
thinking not but even if we did I kind
of feel like I think I felt like back
then it's like well that kind of needs
its own show and now here it is yeah um
but yeah this is one of the things
somebody said uh they saw this on in
search of which um it's creepy that was
a creepy old show yeah well this is kind
of a creepy story I kind of feel like
you know there's oh there's something
really creepy about just abandoned
places in general you know that's that's
why there's so much talk nowadays about
like liminal spaces and uh you know even
like analog horror where they do like
back rooms like with all this empty you
know and abandoned malls and stuff yeah
and um but I kind of feel like it's 100
times creepier when it's a [__] ship
and there's not really I mean there's an
explanation for what happened but nobody
really knows exactly what it is it the
whole the whole Ghost Ship or ship a
ship that just floats around out in the
ocean just with nobody on it
that became creepy as [__] to me when I
was a kid and saw an old B horror movie
called Death Ship yeah and it was about
oh SS [__]
interrogation ship of some sort I don't
remember what it was exactly
but it was it was just a fishing trowel
or a big old Earth big ass fishing boat
that would that that the SS had taken
over and it was floating around out
there was a big movie about it and uh
they were torturing people on it I think
it was like um
too long ago I don't know if we ever
actually reviewed it
and uh some people at Sea right into
this thing and it's just floating around
out there and there's [__] bodies on
it and all kinds of crazy [__] and it's
haunted too turns out it's haunted and
the the SS Captain is still in charge
yeah I think the crew is still in charge
too yeah we did that because we want to
see that one again yeah Danny Rowling
said you reviewed that film yeah I
thought we did I thought we'd like
watched it or reviewed it like just a
few months ago probably not months years
no it wasn't that long ago I think we
were at this house
okay yeah I guess I think you're right
we saw it at this house yeah might have
been 15 months ago 12 months ago maybe a
year ago Hugo said I really like the
beginning of Ghost Ship the one where
everybody gets cut in half by the Yeah
by the thing coming down like that
that's other than that I kind of feel
like
that opening scene is so great that the
rest of the movie kind of the best of
the movie is okay too but it's like it's
hard to top that you know it's like he
they kind of blew their load like right
at the beginning of the movie and
they're like no we don't know what to do
that was like so awesome but uh yeah
this is the film with George yeah George
Kennedy he was the one that played the
the main guy it was called Dead ship
wouldn't it yeah yeah because like I
said there's another one called Ghost
Ship yeah which came out in the 90s 90
it was the 90s right the one where
everybody gets kind of half of the video
yeah yeah I don't remember it's been a
long time yeah but uh
just the concept of a ship out there at
sea
fully furnished just rotting basically
drifting around aimlessly with maybe
ghosts on it and then later on I just
heard rumors that ships like that
actually existed that goes into when I
was a teenager I was hearing about that
there were ships that were just lost at
sea nobody on them floating around it
might have been that one that was lost
for 50 years you said the people would
see it every now and then
yeah I think it was called It's called
The baychinko or something like that I
think we talked about it on the Ghost
Ship show it I think it got like stuck
in the ice at some point and then like
the crew died or I don't remember
exactly all the details but yeah it's
just like floated around yeah and then
years and years then there were stories
you don't know if it's true but people
people would run into the ship and board
the ship
from their little boat or whatever you
know a little private yacht that they
were on and find all kinds of weird [__]
on there and they couldn't stop the ship
it couldn't drop anchor and things they
just had to get back on their ship and
it drifted away lost again you know I
mean they said well this is where we saw
the ship but by the time they send
somebody over there it's long gone
um but weird [__] like
a ship filled with current [__] filled
with cannibalistic rats that's one of
the ones that I heard of I don't know I
don't know how long
the biomass of rats could sustain
themselves through cannibalism that's
got to be inefficient that must have
been yeah you would think because
normally that you know they wouldn't
revert to cannibalism unless they were
kind of like start so how could they
reproduce heavy cannibals at the same
time they would just eat themselves down
to nothing I guess and then maybe it
would grow but there wouldn't be enough
bio material on there to keep them doing
that you know right unless there was
some kind of food intake down in the dam
battles of the ship maybe there was some
[__] fish would come into a hole in
the side or something but even that
wouldn't be able to sustain anything
yeah because there would just be like
one fish going like oh [__] yeah
somebody sent us a bit thank you Bryce
you guys need a super thanks that way
people can drop you some money even if
they missed the live stream yeah we do
have that uh we do have that what's the
word activated yeah yeah uh oldest dirt
says I love stories like this we have it
activated it takes my mind off my life
thing we have it activated on most of
the shows some of the shows were not
monetized well only a couple of them
were I didn't monetize the Gary Webb one
because I figured that was going to get
demonetized anyway I would have just let
him demonetize but yeah but it's like a
pain in the ass and sometimes they're
like hey we're gonna take it down if
it's a live stream because normally what
I do the live streams
um usually you have to wait I think it's
12 hours
um and then you can download it so
usually as soon as I'm able to download
it I'll download it and back it up
because I do um I'll have a backup of it
and I put it in my Dropbox and then like
I pull out the audio so I can put it on
the audio podcast uh kind of stream or
whatever so I do have all the live
streams still but I'm always like scared
that if something like if we say
something sideways or something like
that they're going to take the live
stream down before I get a chance to
download it and then I won't have a
backup I have a backup of every single
live stream we've ever done though I
keep them so you know what I mean so so
don't worry about that like if they get
taken down I could just put it right
back up again
so uh so yeah now we have a couple of uh
shout outs that we wanted to get to
before we get into the main part of the
show
uh I don't remember if I I think I
thanked him before but it might have
been like on one of the you know movie
review shows or something like that and
I always like to thank people on the
main show
um Jonathan
who sent me a PayPal tip a very generous
one so thank you very much Jonathan and
also sent me a message about how much he
enjoyed the show thank you thank you
very much uh also I want to give thanks
to Dermot one of our uh listeners in the
UK for sending me an Amazon gift card so
that I could rent Barton Fink the Coen
Brothers movie which I haven't seen in a
long time because we brought that up
when we were talking about Fargo and I
was like oh yeah I've been wanting to
watch that again because that's a
[__] weirdest weirdest L movie and I
haven't seen it in a long time speaking
of weird as hell movies last night Tom
went to bike night and I was like
scrolling through all the movies and I'm
on Amazon Prime and they had Being John
Malkovich and I was like oh I haven't
seen that like in so long and I remember
that being really good holy crap I
forgot how [__] bizarre and hilarious
that movie is I had such a good time
watching and like re-watching it maybe
I'll do a review of it but I still have
to do um I have another movie that I
have to review first before I do that
though and also uh Louis who always
sends us awesome movies and we still
haven't done Breakfast Club yet that's
kind of the next one we gotta do but he
sent us another movie today we just got
it and here it is it is the steelbook
Edition yes indeed of training day I had
don't know anything about this movie but
Louie's got such good taste you know
yeah
he he perfectly predicts what movie I'm
gonna like so I already know I'm gonna
like the mood yeah he's he's never been
wrong everything he sent me has been
top-notch
been some kind of
steel book Edition I guess when you can
get it you can't always get it he's
always sends me the foot and and the
quality of the movies are always [__]
great and he just predicts my [__]
tone real well of what I like some of my
favorite movies actually were ones that
he showed me
yeah that he sent to me yeah
Santa said training day is Denzel's best
performance I've heard that I don't
think I've seen it I think I've seen
scenes from it but I don't think I've
ever like sat and watched the whole
thing but I've heard it was really good
and yeah everybody says like Denzel
Washington is really good in it yeah and
Trey said another one I can safely say
Tom will love yeah that would be sure
yeah yeah okay yeah I mean like and he
said who said that traded trade it okay
yeah I mean because he sent Pain and
Gain one of my favorite flicks I ended
up really liking that and again I
thought that was a [__] crazy yeah
based on a true story Big Lebowski he
sent that that [__] was awesome
awesome I've never seen that see which I
would have thought that you wouldn't
like no I liked it [__] uh but
[__] uh what was it collateral the
one the one with [__] Tom Cruise
wasn't that called collateral yeah yeah
yeah the [__] uh where was the
Assassin that [__] was off the chain
too just everything he said it's looking
awesome
but that pain again is one of my
favorites man Big Lebowski yeah yeah
real good
yeah Mega said pain again is awesome
yeah pancakes it really is I mean we've
watched it like two or three times yeah
I gotta see it again it keeps getting
funnier every single time I see it
just like Beetlejuice in The Exorcist
yeah but uh but yeah so are we ready to
start talking about the Mary Celeste now
you actually know a little bit about
this case yep
so I thought he did a long time ago yeah
and I feel like Smithsonian uh I read an
article about this earlier today like in
the Smithsonian Magazine where
I mean they know I don't I'm not gonna
say they know what happened because
obviously you know you can't go back in
time to like 1872 or whatever and like
figure out what it was to happen but
I don't know I'm gonna say like what
they came up with is probably pretty
close to what happened
I mean because there's lots of different
things that could have happened but
every single one of them
has things about it that aren't because
I feel like Kevin Smith said earlier
um that he was going with the Pirates
Theory and I was thinking about that too
I'm like yeah that kind of makes sense
but then the more I thought about it I
was like well maybe it doesn't make
sense
they don't have the police blind that's
what I'm saying yeah and I should note
too that the Mary Celeste I kind of feel
like
um
more uh you know spookier more
mysterious details kind of got added
later on
um and some of that was due to like some
of that happened in the early 20th
century and some of that is attributable
to
um good old Sir Arthur Conan Doyle who
wrote a short story several years later
like after The Disappearance of the crew
and me it was a short story about the
Mary Celeste even though he changed the
name of the ship to the Marie Celeste
um but most of the names and stuff were
the same and he came up with like some
crazy I'll get into that a little bit
but
um some of the stuff that he came up
with in there like became
conflated with reality like I've seen
some versions of the story where they
said oh they got on the ship and like
dinner was laid out and all of a sudden
that's it wasn't like that or that or
that there was like no damage to the
ship and there wasn't a lot of damage
but there was a little bit it was like
more than you know it had been it wasn't
completely intact the ship you know what
I mean I mean it was but there was like
yeah it had been at sea for a while
right right right I mean you know
it's nowhere near I mean
there's some creepy [__] about about
this case it is creepy yeah I can
imagine finding this ship as sea would
have been [__] eerie
um but
I don't think it was anything paranormal
well no I don't either obviously but you
know and even though obviously some
people are gonna say oh alien abduction
abduction or Bermuda Triangle type [__]
you know yeah yes or a sea monster I've
seen that or whatever no it wasn't it
wasn't anything like that it was an
emergency
some kind of emergency situation broke
out that's the only explanation
yeah I feel like that's the most likely
yeah they were doing what they could
they were trying to do what they could
to save themselves and probably save the
ship and it didn't work out
um mega said I'm sure Hammer made a film
of this in the 30s yeah they did make
one and I think it was called The
Mystery of the Mary Celeste I don't
think I've seen it
but there was one that had um
there was one that had Bella Lugosi in
it too like playing the ship captain and
he was like a lunatic
but I haven't seen that one either
they've made a bunch of movies about
this I mean yeah and there's been a
bunch of books written about it because
for some reason even though there's lots
of ghost ships but this one really kind
of captured the public imagination I
don't know if it was necessarily because
of the Arthur Conan Doyle story because
I think that came out like eight years
later and that was really popular
um popular enough that like I said
details from the story started getting
like mixed in with the real story but I
don't know why this one caught on and
other ones didn't I guess just because
they never really figured out like what
happened and they never found anybody
there's weirder grosser [__] than this
that actually did happen you can Google
it in modern era just where they've
found a ship adrift a seed had been out
there like five or six years and the
dude's dead in the ship of a heart
attack
up on the table like that died of a
heart attack but he's just mummified
covered in
covered in light in [__] mold and you
can definitely see that's a [__] dead
dude and that ship was out there like
four or five years just drifting around
so spooky really because it's like well
yeah because then you kind of think that
it would just be like dead quiet all you
would hear was like the rocking of the
ship and like the wind like seagulls and
stuff and then that dead body would just
be laying there yeah that's like so
spooky yeah like thinking about that
it's like this rain or shine [__]
through all the seasons yeah things like
all storms and stuff and he's just in
there like not moving because he's
[__] dead it's like that's yeah
that's really creepy I don't know why I
don't know why that's creepy but yeah
Camp guy said like an old lemon molding
exactly so he was still sitting there so
yeah how long was well wait a minute
what I was gonna say was like how long
was the ship out there because like four
or five years so because you would think
that like the storm would have come
along and like knock him out the chair
or something like that no he was or was
it was like a booth you know like a
booth where you eat inside oh okay I got
you you know what I mean and he was uh
remember if memory serves it was a booth
yeah okay inside a boat yeah ship you
know and all I think all the doors and
windows are closed so it's not like he
was just in a chair where he could like
flop out and he was leaning forward on
the table of the boot and the wall was
next to him he was right up against the
window okay
you're taking pictures of him
and I think part of the roof had caved
in a little bit over time yeah probably
it was out there for a while
that blows my mind that like a ship can
just like float around well they float
around for years in those [__] docks
that's true you know
without like without anybody steering it
you'd think but I mean the ocean's big
it's big you're nothing to hit and
there's nothing to hit right yeah so
that's the thing
so let's start talking about the history
of the Mary Celeste now here was
something that I didn't really know that
much about until I started researching
this show
but the Mary Celeste did not start out
life as the Mary Celeste now
I've heard I don't know a huge amount
about like sailor lore and stuff but
Sailors particularly back in the 19th
century tended to be a very
superstitious lot and I kind of think
that one of the no-nos is that you're
not supposed to change the name of a
ship that's supposed to be like bad luck
I think uh so this ship actually like I
said it didn't start out as the Mary
Celeste it got its name changed like
later on and some people said you know
that that maybe had something to do with
it but it should be noted that a bunch
of bad [__] happened before it was even
called the Mary Celeste and it also had
I don't know how widespread
um this perception was but the ship
before it was renamed
um was kind of considered a little bit
to be maybe cursed a little bit
um just because some weird [__] happened
I don't believe in curses or nothing
like that but I'm just saying that weird
[__] happened on the ship like prior to
it being the Mary Celeste uh Crowley
said All Ships back then were female
yeah yeah yeah yeah we have a new person
subjective perspective Collective hey
now just subscribed glad to be here
thank you very much welcome to the
lunatic asylum
hopefully uh you enjoy the show we're
going up I don't know if you've seen any
of our other stuff but we we try to keep
on topic um but we don't try very hard
so a lot so a lot of times we just kind
of go up on settlements and stuff like
that but you know what I mean
so um all right so before this Mary
Celeste was the Mary Celeste it was
actually called the Amazon and it was uh
they started building it in 1860 uh in
Nova Scotia
now the ship it was a Brigantine which
has two masts
and her maiden voyage uh was in May of
1861.
now when she started out uh she was
about 99 feet long uh 25 and a half feet
wide and about 11.7 feet deep now she
was owned by there were like nine owners
there was like a Consortium like a
company that owned it
and one of the guys that was one of the
owners was a guy named Robert McClellan
who was the first captain of what was
then called the Amazon
so on her maiden voyage
um the Amazon went to a place called
five Islands in Nova Scotia and they
were going to take a bunch of lumber
across the Atlantic they were taking it
to London
so as he would do the captain uh Captain
McClellan he was supervising the loading
of the cargo onto the ship
and uh he started not feeling too good
so he actually got uh really sick and
then he just got sicker and sicker and
sicker
now when the Amazon actually got back to
Spencer's Island uh the captain died
so Captain number one dead there will be
more spoiler alert but yeah he just died
of an illness after you know going on
the maiden voyage which like I said a
lot of people were kind of like well
that's that's not good because like I
said very superstitious so anytime
anything like that happens on a ship
they're gonna be like man I don't like
that
so the next guy that took over his
captain
was a guy named John nutting Parker
which is a hilarious name yeah that's a
porn name
John nutting he's yeah he's nothing yeah
oh my goodness
John nunning daily
oh that's even better nothing daily
conceivably be a real laughing yeah you
could just spell it d-a-l-y yeah yeah
that's it
I was watching um because some of you
guys say you also watch Simon Whistler
and his 40 bajillion YouTube channels
seriously the dude I think he has like
30 different YouTube channels where he
has like a crime one he has like a
paranormal one he has like a mystery one
and he did like a 45 minute show on the
Mary Celeste and he was kind of laughing
at that dude's name and he said I feel
like nutting should be in like in the
Parks or something like that and I was
like yeah right because he's like the
poor guy I don't know if that translates
to any of our foreign audience
hahaha
nutting is a slam term for busting a nut
well I mean you know I think they well
obviously they thought if Simon Whistler
is British okay so they have it there so
they thought it was funny he thought it
was funny anyway but
um but yeah uh so so he took over uh
nutting yeah that's what we're gonna
call him yeah he took over as the
captain and uh yes takes over now
it's a threesome
I'm tired you take over oh this is
already going downhill
the discourse is going down with the
ship it's like back in high school me
and Steve high five in each other go
ahead man your turn
Danny Rolex said Tom's porn name should
be hard r
I do like the nutting thing though that
would be funny because I like it because
it also kind of like I said it has like
a um like a historical precedent like
so you can you can be like all like
high-minded about it which is kind of
neat
so uh so yeah so nutting takes over his
captain and you know kept kept on going
to London like I said to do the timber
now while he was going to London
um or either going to or coming back
from London rather he was in this uh
this narrow passage like off of Maine
and ran into some uh fishing stuff not a
boat but I think there was like Nets or
some other [__] like that so there was
like a little debacle there
and then after they left London uh they
ran into another boat and sank it so
damn you know this uh rammed about the
boat they rammed another boat yeah like
accidentally I'm beginning to think that
nutting was maybe nutting and not
steering the ship yes perhaps maybe he
should stop danger day drinking it was
him in the cabin boy
because he's out he's just running into
[__] it's like what I could I could
drive the boat I'm fine papal
hitting the fish and [__] hitting
another boat you sacked by Brick you
[__] [__]
but yeah
now
um despite his hitting [__] everywhere
um nutting if Parker was his last name
but I'm just gonna call him nothing he
actually was in command of what was then
called the Amazon for two years
now during this time uh the Amazon was
in the West Indies mostly
and uh actually in 1861 like late 1861
they think that when she was in uh
France that was when the very famous
painting of her if you Google the Mary
Celeste it's pretty much the first
picture that'll come up is like a
painting that was done of her and they
think that it was probably done in
France in 1861.
so the next guy that took over like
nutting was fine other than hitting
everything
um you know uh Parker didn't didn't die
at least like having to do with the ship
he died eventually I'm sure unless he's
a vampire yeah but so uh so nutting he
was you know on there until 1863
and then in 1867 or no the next guy that
took over was a guy named William
Thompson he was on there until 1867 the
league server for the next four years
now during these four years it seems
like nothing untoward happened like I
said I'm not sure I've seen like
different sources say that even back
then like before it was the Mary's
Celeste like it had a reputation for
being cursed a little bit just because
the first Captain had died and then like
it kept hitting boats and [__] like that
like [__] kept going wrong but I don't
know how widespread that perception was
like I said but during the four years
that William Thompson was the captain it
seems like there weren't really records
of a lot of weird actually were like you
know [__] this noise and they just you
know proceed they just claimed it as a
wreck you know what I mean because it
was just too it would have been too
expensive to fix it
so she was actually sold uh to a guy
named Alexander McBean who was these
names man not nutting McMahon Jesus
Christ
um who was uh from Nova Scotia and he
bought it uh as a derelict and I guess
that that's kind of like that's what he
would do he would like buy these boats
and like sell sell them on so he
actually ended up selling the wreck of
the Amazon
to another guy who was like a local
businessman and then that guy resold it
to an American dude uh named Richard
Haynes
now at the time now this was a wrecked
ship essentially I mean it was still a
ship but it was it had been kind of
smushed on the Rocks you know what I
mean
so Haynes paid
back then in back then money and back
then money
1790 1 750 dollars
and back then money and I looked that up
I was like well how much is that today
about 37 Grand is how much that is uh
for the rack of the ship
and then uh he proceeded to spend in
back then money uh 800
fixing it up which in today's money is
about 187 thousand dollars
um and he made himself the captain
because that's kind of what you do you
buy a wreck and then you spend all that
money fix it up and you're like I
[__] run this [__] that's what I'm
gonna do
and at this point this man here Haynes
was the guy who I guess he figured since
he had essentially like re-did the boat
he's like well I'm gonna rename it which
like I said I've heard that that's kind
of bad luck you know what I mean and
like I said I don't believe in that kind
of stuff but a lot of sailors do
so he went and renamed the vessel the
Mary Celeste now evidently I don't think
okay so this is my perception
that if you rename the ship you have to
have like a renaming ceremony right like
it has to be like official and I don't
think he did that like he did register
it like you have to go through legal
channels and everything like that but he
didn't have like a party or like an
official renaming ceremony or nothing
like that which I think a lot of some
people like pointed to is like ooh that
you shouldn't do that but yeah he but he
was the guy that renamed it the Mary
Celeste because he was the one that
spent all that money rebuilding it
now uh he didn't have it for very long
though
old Haynes he did because he wasn't
paying the bills so he actually the the
boat essentially got repoed the very
Celeste and at that point it got sold on
to another like group like a Consortium
uh which was headed by a guy named James
Winchester
and during the next three years uh the
kind of the the guys that were that had
ownership of this you know ship kind of
changed out a bunch of times although
Winchester was kind of the one constant
he actually did have a half share of the
ship like throughout now there's not
really much
um record of what the Mary Celeste was
up to during this time it seems like it
was just doing regular you know trade
runs and things like that like that like
a regular ship would do
now in 1872 early in the year
um the ship underwent yet another like
major overhaul
um and it cost the Consortium back then
about ten thousand dollars which is
about uh 212
000 in today's money and this renovation
actually they made it a lot bigger
um they actually made it because
remember I said it started out at 99.3
feet and then they expanded it they
lengthened it to 103 feet and then they
uh widened it a little bit and uh
deepened it by about five feet and they
also added a second deck and it's like
some other things so they kind of like
kitted it out you know what I mean like
replaced a bunch of the wood and
everything
so one of the guys as it turned out like
in October Of 1872 that was that was uh
kind of came on and like purchased some
shares of the ship was a guy named
Benjamin Spooner Briggs who was the guy
that was gonna be the captain on the
Mary celeste's doomed last voyage
what wasn't really her last Voyage it
was just the one where everybody
disappeared because they did find the
ship and like it you know they it's
still they still used it like afterward
so Benjamin Briggs
he was from Massachusetts
um and his dad was a sea captain as was
his brother
and uh basically he was he was real
Christian
um you know he was very very upstanding
and like you know real into like reading
the Bible and everything like that uh he
had a wife named Sarah Cobb who was also
his cousin uh which you know weird but
it's was it was pretty common back then
uh and they had two kids uh Arthur
uh and Sophia Matilda who I think was
only two years old at the time of the
incident
now Briggs was actually a very very well
respected uh sea captain like like I
said very upstanding nobody had a bad
word to say about him
now ironically given what ended up
happening to him which is kind of sad
but him and his brother Oliver who like
I said was also a sea captain they were
kind of getting to the point where like
bro I'm like I'm really sick of like you
know sailing around the world like on
ships and everything maybe we should
like settle down you know because they
both had wives and small children at
that point and they didn't really want
to be gone for months at a time so they
said maybe we should you know pool our
resources and you know kind of get into
like a land business rather than like
sailing around the world
however that's
sadly unfortunately for them uh that's
not what they did they decided instead
that they were each going to invest in a
different ship so Oliver invested in one
and uh Benjamin ended up as I said
investing in the Mary Celeste and
Benjamin Briggs was the one that uh
became captain of the Mary Celeste on
her first voyage after she had been you
know substantially enlarged and kitted
out
now this particular Voyage was they were
going to sail from New York City
to Genoa Italy
and basically they were going to take a
cargo what the cargo was was about a
thousand like a thousand plus barrels of
denatured alcohol so it wasn't like
drinking alcohol but it was just like
industrial alcohol or methylated Spirits
or whatever
now his wife and his little baby
daughter who just isn't a baby she was
two
um but they were gonna come with him now
his son Arthur who I think was seven at
the time of this happening they were
actually gonna leave him at home uh with
the grandparents because he was still in
school and they didn't want to take him
out
so he was actually spoiler alert the
only one of the family that ended up uh
surviving the immediate family anyway
so Briggs like I said very respected sea
captain and he was very careful about
the crew that he chose this is a very
small crew because like I said it wasn't
a passenger ship it was a you know it
was a cargo ship
so he everybody that he picked either he
had sailed with them before or they came
with like Sterling recommendations from
somebody else that he knew
so it was basically like um he had I
think it was like a total of it was him
and his wife and his kid and then I
think it was like seven other people so
like I said it was just like a pretty
small crew it wasn't like you know it
wasn't the Titanic or anything like that
it was like thousands of people on it
and in his letters they still have some
of his letters that survived that like
he wrote to his mom and stuff like that
um he told them that they were all first
class Sailors and he was you know
looking forward to the journey he
thought it was going to be a good one
yeah that wasn't how that worked out
so in October late October 1872.
Benjamin Briggs shows up uh at the port
in New York City and he's supervising
the loading of the cargo as I said uh it
was 1700 barrels of denatured alcohol
now his wife and his baby daughter were
actually going to come to New York City
like a week later so you know because he
was waiting and they were you know
putting the stuff on the ship and
everything like that
now he wrote a letter to his mother
um before he left and uh very famously
the quote was our vessel is in beautiful
trim and I hope we shall have a fine
passage again that's not what ended up
happening
so basically they went from the for the
from the uh the pier where they were and
then they all got on the ship and then
they went into the harbor however the
weather was kind of shitty and they
weren't really sure if they were safe
kind of like going out into the open
ocean so they said well let's wait a
couple of days and see like if the
weather gets better
so they actually anchored the ship off
of Staten Island and um you know they
still have a letter from Sarah the wife
um you know to her mother like talking
about their son and everything like that
so they waited there for two days
and then they set out into the Atlantic
Ocean
now
for a while everything appeared to be
fine but there was another ship
uh called the de gratia
which is I think is Latin for by the
grace of God or something like that and
this was a Canadian uh brigandine
now this ship was taking about the same
route like the same General Route it was
also going to Genoa with another cargo
and it was going to sail about eight
days behind the um the Mary Celeste they
were actually carrying a petroleum
now the captain of that ship was named
David Morehouse
and
there's been speculation like it's
they're pretty sure that he at least
knew Benjamin Briggs you know the
captain of the Mary Celeste some of the
reports I saw said oh they had dinner
like before the Fateful Journey or
whatever nobody knows if that's the case
that story actually comes from David
morehouse's Widow like you know 50 years
later or something like that so I'm not
really sure if that's true or not but
for sure they probably knew each other
at least as casual acquaintances
so uh so yeah so he was gonna basically
set out on the same route but he wasn't
expecting to run into the Mary Celeste
because the Mary Celeste was won a
faster ship and was eight days ahead and
even though they were going to the same
place there's probably no way that his
ship uh the de gratia could have caught
up to them to the Mary's Celeste had
what happened uh not happen
so the day gratia
um actually got into this area which was
like halfway between uh the Azores and
the coast of Portugal they reached there
about uh in the afternoon of December
4th 1872. interestingly it says December
4th 1872 land time and then it says
Thursday December 5th C time because
apparently sea time used to be different
than land time and I was just sitting
there going how [__] confusing is
that what I read I don't know if this is
true or not and maybe anybody that's you
know knows a lot about like um
you know Mariner history or anything
like that can tell me but I read
somewhere that before they really had
like the whole time zone thing locked
down you were considered to be in the
same time zone like if you were on a
ship you were considered to be on the
same time zone as the times under the
place that you left like even if you
were hundreds and thousands of miles
away weird which I was like what how did
that work like everybody now it's like a
different day because that's when they
started counting time yeah I guess so
they wouldn't know it'd be like what
it's tomorrow yeah what the [__] I'm
like that doesn't make any sense to me
at all everybody was on their own time I
remember time didn't matter
evidently not yeah because I mean people
still got [__] done but it's just kind
of like I thought we were gonna meet on
the fifth it is the fifth you know what
I mean it's like you know that was
yesterday we kind of had the same
problem in the Infantry
um
we didn't use calendars we used Mission
day
you know what I mean be like a day seven
day eight yeah
day nine it'd be like
that's just how that's just how we did
it we didn't really worry about what
date what the outside world date was we
had our own date
we're just making [__] up yeah we may
not know what day it was when you left
because right sleep deprivation and [__]
like that you know yeah I gotcha yeah
so uh so yeah so the day gratia
Captain by Captain Morehouse I almost
said Captain whorehouse yeah
see see what happens when one person is
named nutting it just throws off my
whole game yeah but yeah so Captain
Morehouse they get this ship and they
see another ship off in the distance
what is it like I said it's not weird
it's you know it's the ocean you know
every now and then you're gonna see
another ship
but they the captain was like looking at
it through his little Spyglass or
whatever and he's like that's this
something's not right it's like that's
moving weird it was kind of moving
toward them but it was like still kind
of far away
so uh also there was like the the way
the sales were set was unusual so he
thought something was wrong
so he's like okay we need to go over
there and check that out because maybe
they're in trouble
so they go over there
um and through the Spyglass they
couldn't see anybody on the ship like
nobody on deck which uh you know again
very strange
um you know nobody hailed them nobody
did anything and uh he signaled to the
other ship and obviously nobody replied
so he um the first mate and the second
mate he was like why don't you go over
there in the little in the little dinghy
or whatever and like see what the hell
is going on over there then investigate
so the two of them go over to the other
ship and they see that this ship is the
Mary Celeste because obviously it's
written right there on the start
so the two of them climbed on board the
Mary Celeste and found the ship was
completely deserted
now as I said the ship wasn't in perfect
condition but it was in decent condition
I mean it was still obviously seaworthy
because it was floating around and you
know as we'll find out later they
actually did like the other guy got on
the ship and took it you know what I
mean so um the sales were set you know
like only partly set and they were kind
of tattered a little bit uh with a
couple of them missing
um some of the rigging was damaged and
you know with a couple of ropes like
hanging over the side now the main hatch
cover was fine uh it looked completely
normal but some of the other a couple of
the other hatches were
um open and like that somebody looked
like they had taken the hatches off and
like put them down on the deck or
whatever
um and also very famously the ship's
single Lifeboat only only had one
Lifeboat was uh Missing
also uh the thing that had the ship's
compass in it was um the glass was
broken
there was also about three and a half
feet of water in the hold which sounds
like a lot but for a ship that size not
really that it wouldn't have um really
affected the anything you know what I
mean like it wouldn't have it's you know
wouldn't have been like oh my God the
ship's sinking or anything like that
so it wasn't really a big deal there was
also and this was
um maybe uh uh clue as to maybe what
happened
there was a sounding Rod but it wasn't
the sounding Rod that was like normally
with the ship it was just kind of like a
janky like
um thrown together one so I guess I
don't know where This ship's actual
sounding Rod was but they just had
something else that they were using as a
sounding rod and it's the thing that
they used to like to find out how much
water is in the hold right so they found
that and that was on the deck also
they also found uh the ship's log the
final entry was uh November 25th which
was nine days before they had found the
ship
the Mary Celeste position at that point
um was like right off the right off
Santa Maria Island in the Azores now
this was about 400 nautical miles away
from where the uh ship was eventually
found
so yeah the ship floated a long time
now the first mate went and investigated
saw that the Interiors of the cabin were
like kind of wet like some of the water
had come in and stuff like that but
nothing was out of place like
everybody's stuff was in the closet like
where it should be
um nothing was really knocked over or
disturbed or anything like that
everything looked pretty normal it's
just like a little raggedy but nothing
like terribly weird
um now there were kind of like in
briggs's Cabin he was the you know the
captain there was
um there was a couple personal items
kind of scattered around not not
anything a big deal there was also like
a really nice sword like in a sheath
like under his bed like you know really
really nice one now most of the ship's
papers though like the official papers
were missing
and um both of the captains like the
Captain's personal navigational
instruments were also missing although
the log book was still there as I
mentioned
um but there was
like I said there was nothing to suggest
like there there were kind of like
stories later that you know they went on
the ship and there was like you know
candles burning and there was like
dinner laid out on the table that's not
the case they um there was no food out
there was nothing like that but the ship
did have enough food in it like that
people could have lived on this ship for
like six months so it's not like based
on everything that was missing the
abandoned ship that's what you take with
you all the log books and
important papers the compass that's when
they broke the glass they broke the
glass to get the compass out
I'm guessing yeah well the glass cover
thing from the thing that held the
compass was broken so yeah I guess they
must think they took the main Compass
right the good compass
yeah yeah and I think like the Captain's
like his sex stent and the uh and um so
they could navigate yeah and then they
got into the missing boat the missing uh
uh what dinghy what they call it the
life rafter we got them yeah
so it happens so for some reason they
thought they had to abandon ship we'll
see that's kind of yes that's with all
evidence points of that that's what the
mystery is yeah
now interestingly so the first mate like
he goes and he's like man this is some
weird ass [__] I don't want to happen to
all these people
um so he goes back to the main ship and
says to the captain uh you know what
what the hell so uh because of the rules
of the sea
you find a ship out there that's
abandoned in derelict uh you can claim
it Salvage
so um it was still seaworthy as I said
so they're like okay well we're gonna
sail this to we're gonna sail to Mary
Celeste to Gibraltar which was 600
nautical miles away
um now you wouldn't get the whole value
I think like you got I don't remember
what the um exact percentage was because
they didn't end up getting it like
spoiler alert but you would get like a
percentage of the value like if you
brought it back
nobody else claimed it blah blah
so
um I think that like the more dangerous
it was to salvage it like the more money
you got which seems fair
so basically the thing about it was that
the de gratia only had I think it only
had eight dudes on it
so three dudes got on the Mary Celeste
and you know steered that toward
Gibraltar and then the other five dudes
stayed on the de grantia and they were
also going to Gibraltar they were like
following imagine those three dudes are
creeped out that's what I was saying
it's like to be like I wouldn't have had
a ship I would have to like draw straws
it's like man I don't want to do that
yeah it's like this [__]
Ben said weren't the finders accused of
massacring the crew to steal a ship yes
they were uh yeah we'll get into that in
a couple minutes but um yeah that was
that was one of the theories
about what happened
so so yeah so the two vessels and so
like I said they didn't like the the
Mary Celeste was in totally fine order
like they didn't apparently have any
trouble like steering at 600 nautical
miles like to Gibraltar they did run
into like some bad weather like some fog
and stuff like that so it took them like
a day longer to get there than the day
grazia did so the de grazia got there
first and then the Mary Celeste got
there the next day but they didn't have
any uh problems uh getting there
so uh they start doing the court hearing
for the Salvage in Gibraltar in kind of
a few days before Christmas of 1872.
so the this is hilarious to me
so the guy like the judge guy that was
presiding over the Salvage hearing was
this dude named Frederick Sally flood
like that was in his last name was
hyphenated he was the Attorney General
of Gibraltar now one historian this is a
quote that I heard like on a lot of
these and I just thought it was too
funny like not to repeat it one
historian uh said
uh that Frederick Sally flood was a man
and this is a quote whose arrogance and
pomposity were inversely proportional to
his IQ damn I'm like harsh damn all
right
he sounds yeah he sounded like an
[__] uh he sounded like an [__]
like a [__] by all uh accounts
uh also the sort of man who once he made
up his mind about something couldn't be
shifted yeah which you know that's not
really that sounds like somebody who has
[__] third stage syphilis
remission yeah
they do that or maybe he's just a dick I
don't know yeah
but you know that's what they're
describing yeah the sea back then yeah
maybe he might have have recovered for
syphilis
perhaps because once they make I don't
know they can't change their mind I
don't know if this guy had been at Sears
yeah he was just the Attorney General he
was the guy that was presiding over the
Salvage I don't I don't know I don't
know like enough about it so he be very
well Mayhem he got Sif somewhere I don't
really know
but um apparently
he heard um the first and second mate of
the day gratia and they basically went
on and told him you know in the hearing
like what they had found on board the
Mary Celeste and uh Sully there Sally
flood
but that's also a silly name
he kind of came to the conclusion that
uh some murder was afoot and again could
not really be dissuaded from this uh
belief and he he seemed to think that
the crew
either the crew of the de gratia the
ones that had found the ship or the crew
of the Mary Celeste had gotten into the
alcohol in the cargo and had gone insane
and killed everybody oh well that's a
theory
it's certainly a theory it happens to me
every time
not a good one mind you but it is a
theory well and the thing about it was
that it wasn't drinking alcohol anyway
and it's like yeah you could drink that
if you really wanted to but I'm not
really sure if you'd be in much shape to
be killing people probably could go
blind that's what I'm saying it's like I
don't I don't really think he'd be he'd
be [__] high as a [__] kite
he's tripping yeah I'm just I don't know
he's trying to blame somebody yeah I
kind of feel like yeah so a couple days
before Christmas December 23rd uh Sully
Sully flood he had somebody go on board
like he had a diver and all that other
kind of stuff and they go on board the
Mary Celeste and like do this you know
do some CSI [__] on there
now what they found allegedly
and they found out later this wasn't
true so I'm just I'm spoiling it right
there
but there was one of the guys that
examined the ship he said oh we found
these cuts on the side of the bow which
they think was caused by a sharp
instrument
and also the captain's sword because
remember I said he had like a sword that
was sheath like under his bed in his
cabin
um looked like it had blood on it now
this okay so uh he's like the guy also
said like in his report so he's like
yeah his blood and there's cuts it looks
like there was violence and he also said
it doesn't look like the ship went
through any bad weather and I'm like
well what about all the ripped up sales
and the ropes and everything I mean that
looks like some bad weather maybe I
don't know but he like I said they kind
of had one narrative and they wanted to
go with it I guess
so
so basically also they um they had
another guy come on and he said also
that he thought these cuts on the bow
had been deliberately caused and that
there were stains on the one of the
ship's railings that also might have
been blood
um and then there was a deep Mark there
that said oh it was an ax so he they're
basically trying to make it seem like
like I said they that somebody got into
the alcohol and like killed everybody
with an ax and a sword and there was
blood everywhere and stuff like that but
that's um actually not the case
so these reports though got sent to you
know the higher-ups or whatever
and like I said that was his story they
got into the alcohol the crew of the
Mary Celeste got into the alcohol and
killed the Briggs family and then you
know nobody knows what happened after
that I don't know
so he's thought too that maybe the crew
of the de gratia he thought that another
possibility was that the de gratia had
actually either the captain Morehouse
and Captain Briggs had conspired to get
like Salvage rights or insurance money
or something like that so they're like
well you pretend to like find the ship
like abandoned and then we'll take it in
until like they have this whole plot
going so they even either either thought
that the two captains like conspired to
get insurance money like insurance fraud
or that the de gratia like had planned
to waylay the Mary Celeste kill
everybody on board and then to get the
Salvage raids so I kind of feel like the
like as soon as they got there with the
ship
you know the dude in Gibraltar was like
suspicious because he's like well you
know everyone's gone and like your story
doesn't add up and blah blah blah so
it's like you guys killed them like to
get the ship which I don't know it just
seems like a far-fetched I'm not saying
it's impossible yeah it just doesn't fit
that yeah it really it doesn't sign a
[__] combat no blood spilled on the
ship there's just that doesn't sound
like a crime spree crime yeah because
like I said they said well they cleaned
it up and by the time they got the ship
you know because that's the condition of
the ship and as far as the story was
given by the guys who discovered it and
if the guys had discovered it
killed people and they could lie about
the condition of the ship when they
found and clean up them but I don't
believe that's what it was I think I
believe they were telling the truth they
found the ship abandoned in good
condition well and they found out later
too that like the stuff on the sword and
like the stuff on the ship wasn't blood
anyway yeah and they found out that the
cuts on there were like not were just
caused by like weather and like natural
stuff it wasn't like nobody was going
around there with an ax like doing a
jack Torrance or nothing like that
they've I mean you know they figured
that out later on
so um so basically the guy Winchester
who was you know the guy who was like
the main owner he was like half owner so
he shows up in Gibraltar in January 15th
and he's like well um you know we need
to deliver the ship because we still
have all the [__] on the boat that we
need to like deliver to General because
that's like a lot of money yeah
now at this point uh Sally flood the the
guy with the the Arrogant pompous dude
he um asked for fifteen thousand dollars
from Winchester like to release the ship
now Winchester is like [__] you man I
don't have fifteen thousand that's who
the [__] has fifteen thousand dollars
just like here especially back then God
damn it that's probably like a million
dollars back then
um so at this point Winchester who like
I said is the half owner of the ship he
started he figured out that Sally flood
thought that he was kind of like casting
his versions on Winchester's name
because he's like well you're implying
that I hired a crew that would kill the
captain and his wife and his baby
daughter just in order to like either
because in a drunken frenzy or in order
to like collect insurance so like
yeah he got offended you know what I
mean as you would yeah
um so him and flood gotten uh they
didn't get in like a fist fight I don't
think I don't think although how awesome
would that have been like there's been
mustache wax and [__] like that flying
everywhere this is the 19th century
they're just gonna fight anywhere
they're slapping each other
[Laughter]
laughs
you have offended me deeply sir
but yeah it's just slapping each other
they're all skinny fat but yeah so um so
that but they had some uh verbal
exchanges yeah for sure like had some
little uh little tips there yeah
and uh basically Winchester is like look
I know Briggs he wouldn't have
um done anything like to do insurance
fraud or anything like that none of the
all of the crew were just unimpeached
words unimpeachable unimpeachable uh of
care unimpeachable character and he also
said that Briggs he's like look he was a
really experienced sailor he'd been
doing this [__] for a really long time
it's like he wouldn't have abandoned the
ship unless something was really wrong
you know I mean he wouldn't just you
know he was used to bad weather he was
used to ships yeah so it had to be
something like really bad or he thought
that it was really bad otherwise he
wouldn't have done Jenny called him a
sailor and they'd get mad over that they
were men of the sea they were seeming
I don't want to say semen yeah I already
had to say nutting and nutting and semen
I already had all these silly names I'm
not gonna say that yeah the ghost from
Ghost of Mr Beer be yelling at you right
about now
yeah that's a great flick that is a
great bit
well that's well I was um I got a sale
it's a sheet I was watching um
uh what what the [__] is the name of
that channel the um
[__] now I can't remember it's like it's
like those two guys that God damn it it
just went totally out of my mind but
like the two funny guys
you guys are probably too funny guys
it's too funny guys and like they do
they have a paranormal Channel and they
have a um a true crime one too and they
did a you know if you saw him because we
watched a bunch of them one time I'll
probably remember it like two minutes
from now but they did a show about this
and they did one where they were all
sitting out by the fire pit and they
were clearly very very inebriated which
was like hilarious you're not the only
ones a good drug yeah well that's what I
was thinking I was watching I'm like oh
my God they're Drucker than we are
that's awesome but because like the dude
was either just like slurring and um
they got to and they went off on a bunch
of digressions too and sieben was one of
them that's why I was reminded because
he told that one of them told the other
guys like I want you to just say semen
with a completely straight face
and he did it even though he was like
super truck they're like wow you did it
but yeah that was like that's why I
thought of that what the [__] is the
name of that BuzzFeed unsolved that's
what it is I knew I would think of it I
knew it was two words BuzzFeed unsolved
but yeah they did one about the Mary
Celeste which was like very funny where
they were very very drunk well one of
them was drunk anyway
so uh so yeah what's funny people so we
don't watch the competition no mostly
they got people doing doing other shows
so we're not really considering the
competition we never even think of them
full watch
um like depending on whatever the topic
is yeah like because I have you know
channels that I like that I would just
watch anyway like I like BuzzFeed
unsolved I like Simon whistler's
channels and so like if they've done
something about it then I'll Pro then
I'll probably watch that if I have time
just so I don't cover the same thing or
like make the same jokes as them or
something like that like without being
the whole time we've been around only a
couple only a couple other channels have
ever contacted us
um
see oh what's his name uh [__] we
haven't he hadn't contacted this in a
long time that other paranormal show
oh [__]
you Fade to Black fade no no
um it's very normal conspiranormal yeah
because paranormal yeah yeah and then
there's another one
um we've done so Mandy I can't remember
yeah
okay I forgot
but yeah so um so as I mentioned uh they
actually determined that the stuff on
the sword was not blood
and uh they took this information to
solid flood and then another guy
um
actually came on the ship and figured
out that the marks on the ship were
actually just accidental
um so you know they put that in their
report as well
so after all of this Sally flood who
apparently can change his mind some
although he wasn't happy about it he
very he was very grudging
but he's like okay well I guess I don't
get to do like the murder Mutiny thing
fine so he
um allowed the Mary Celeste to be
released on February 25th so it could
deliver its cargo
so they had a new captain and uh they
went off and sailed off to Genoa
now it turned out that the Salvage uh
payment that they got
was only 1700 pounds which is probably a
lot of money back then but it was only a
fifth of the value of the ship in the
cargo which was not usually I think
usually you would get half
and I think that he had to split that
like between eight people because there
was eight people on the crew right so
not really um
not really what he was expecting I guess
because he had actually like written to
his wife and say oh I'm you know I found
the ship and I'm gonna get all this
money from it but he didn't get it they
did kind of rip him off well I think
they did that because flood still had
enough power and he still seemed to
think that you know despite everybody
being like look it wasn't murder
um he really really wanted it to be
murdered so I think he still kind of
felt like that the crew of The Dig ratio
was still under suspicion so he didn't
want to like I guess reward them by
giving them all this money you know what
I mean because he still thought they
were guilty even though I'm pretty sure
they weren't like I said it's not
impossible that that's what happened but
I just really doubt it like you know the
evidence just doesn't really support it
was just conclusion a way of trying to
deny them the money
yeah I kind of feel like maybe it was
that too it's like they just didn't want
to give it to him yeah they wanted to
keep it right
so all right so let's talk about the
theories that have swirled in the year
since uh for what happened to the 10
people that were on the Mary Celeste now
as I mentioned uh flood was a big
advocate of the murder scenario
as I said it does seem that
kind of the two branches of this were
either like I said that
uh that the crew of the Mary Celeste
actually went crazy because of the
alcohol and well because I forgot to
mention but
out of this 1700 I think it was 1701
barrels of denatured alcohol
there were a few of them I think eight
or nine of the barrels were empty
however those particular barrels I think
like I said I think it was eight of them
those particular barrels were the only
ones that were in the cargo hold that
were made of red oak instead of white
oak Now red oak is a lot more porous
than white oak so it's been speculated
that maybe the alcohol just kind of
leaked out like or seeped out it didn't
like they weren't broken or anything
like that so and like I said nine Barrel
it's like this is not stuff that you'd
be drinking necessarily
so I don't know why flood was so head up
to be like you know yeah they drank all
this denatured alcohol and then went
crazy and like killed everybody and
because there really wasn't any
there was no sign of violence or
struggle or anything like that on the
ship yeah a couple things were knocked
over but it wasn't like a [__] I mean
if you killed
you know if 10 people it's well they
wouldn't have been killed some 10 people
it would have been like one person
killing nine people or two people
killing eight people whatever but it's
like there would be evidence of that
there would be blood stains that would
be like [__] would be knocked over they
would get hurt doing it right it's like
so i j and and you know if that happened
like where did that guy go like where
did the other two guys you know where
did they go because they never see I
don't buy it either and then like I said
that it was either that like the the
crew did it or that the crew of the de
gratia had planned to Ambush the ship
just so specifically so they could take
it and they killed the crew and threw
them overboard it's all unlikely which I
don't really buy that either most likely
they abandoned ship for some because
they thought they had to
this must have happened at night
they couldn't check on certain
conditions of something they thought
something was wrong it probably had to
do that cargo
maybe uh
maybe they thought the cargo was gonna
catch on fire
for some reason well I'm gonna get into
all that or maybe maybe they smelled
something got it some kind of gas leak
they thought it was gonna blow up
for some reason they thought that they
thought they had to get off in a in a
hurry
yeah no I'm gonna get into that that's
that's one of the theories right yeah
two in a minute I'm still talking about
the Motorola stuff
um
Trey says see all the books I had
claimed dinner was laid out on the
tables yeah and I kind of feel like
that's that's become like urban legend
at this point but that's not the case
that's not true they said there was
actually no food being prepared there's
a bunch of food on the ship like food
stores but there was nothing laid out
although I did read I think there was
another ship like another ghost ship
that was maybe off the coast of
Australia or something like that that um
that had that like where they found the
ship abandoned there was like actually a
meal laid out but I can't remember all
the details of that but that didn't
happen on the Mary Celeste though there
was no dinner laid out so it wasn't like
super sudden but it did seem like
something happened
and they were like yeah we need to get
the [__] off here like immediately
they took all the emergency [__] you're
supposed to take when you abandoned the
ship
yeah but like I okay so like I said
um it seems unlikely that the crew of
the digrattia
um had conspired to you know kill the
crew of the Mary Celeste and blah blah
because like I said they didn't even
leave port until eight days after the
Mary Celeste and they're in if the Mary
Celeste hadn't been abandoned they
wouldn't have caught up to them because
they were much slower like their ship
was much slower so how did they figure
that was gonna work it's just I don't
know it just doesn't seem like that's
the plan
and like I said they you know why would
they do that it just seemed like a
stupid thing to do and they ended up not
getting that much money anyways so
um yeah
so there's also it's also been
speculated that perhaps uh the crew was
uh set upon by Pirates again this is
possible but usually Pirates don't just
board a ship kill everybody throw them
overboard and then just leave the [__]
yeah they steal I mean they want the
ship and the stuff that's kind of the
point of piracy yeah they felt they
couldn't get rid of the ship they would
at least steal the cargo they'd loaded
the cargo out of that ship into their
ship they're taking anything around the
place [__] blind yeah because there
was still like some valuable [__] left
on there that like belonged to some of
the crew like and you know the captain
it was a pirates
so yeah I'm nothing unless the only
thing that I can think of is yeah maybe
Pirates got on board
um you know and either we're like oh the
cargo is worthless which it's not I mean
you can pretty much offload anything but
or but they got on the ship and then
killed everybody and then something else
happened and they're like oh [__] we got
to get off here but like I said that
just goes back to the yeah so it's like
I'm not really buying the pirate thing
either because they didn't take anything
and nothing looked like it had been
rifled through or nothing that's what
would have happened right it [__]
knocked everything over just like in a
house robbery
just take a whole dresser drawers and
just dumping the [__] out you know yeah
just looking for valuable [__] yeah big
piles of [__]
clothes and [__] in the center of the
room where they're just throwing all air
and trying to sort through it as they're
going they're the place of a ransack
literally it would have been ransacked
like I said they probably would have
taken the whole ship too because the
ship was in good shape yeah see you got
time
so they've been on there and they
probably spent the night there yeah it's
not like somebody's gonna drive by yeah
you know what I mean you're in the
middle of [__] ocean yeah
um also there have been some and this is
really kind of crazy some people have
also speculated that Captain Briggs
himself uh flipped out like went into
some kind of weird religious mania and
decided to kill everybody but again
no signs of violence on the ship no
blood no nothing like that and everybody
that knew him was like yeah that's
really not something he wanted it's more
unlikely [__] yeah it's gonna be very
likely
it's been something that had you been
there that made total sense
yeah gotta figure out what that is
so um so okay so now let's kind of talk
about like I said The more a more
plausible scenario now because the
Lifeboat was missing and because really
the only other things missing from the
ship were [__] that you would take with
you in an emergency situation like your
navigational tools and stuff like that
um records most yeah and like the
records of the ship and everything most
people
um you know that don't think it was
Bigfoot or whatever uh you know
speculate that probably something
happened on the ship that made them
think that the ship was going to sink or
possibly explode or something else yeah
was wrong with the ship and it had like
I said it had to be something kind of
dire because most people that knew
Captain Briggs were like he was very
experienced he wouldn't have just like
been a nervous Nelly and like jumped off
the ship at this latest provocation it
would have had to have been something
bad or he thought that it was going to
be something bad it was something that
they thought that they had to do quickly
like they were running out of time right
because they left quickly by what so
yeah and so some people have speculated
this is kind of one of the more
um plausible scenarios to me is that
perhaps
um the fumes from the alcohol that had
leaked out of those empty barrels
um I don't know how long it took like to
leak over but it was supposed to
supposed supposedly
um you know that would cause like a
really uh a bad smell there you go and
so maybe they thought
that um the ship was gonna blow up yeah
and so they thought I don't think though
that they necessarily would have gotten
to the Lifeboat being like you know
we're just gonna get the [__] out of
here some people speculated that they
got in the Lifeboat and like kept it
attached to the boat
so that they were like we're gonna let
the ship air out and then we'll get back
on it like when the fumes or something
like that you know what I mean so that
was another theory but then it happened
that like the Lifeboat somehow became
detached from the main ship the entire
ride or [__] rope broke something or
something like that and then like they
drifted off into the ocean and couldn't
get back to the ship this could have
happened at night so they couldn't
really see down the hole Maybe
maybe it happened at night and they
thought somebody was down there with a
Gas Lantern
and like oh [__] those fumes with that
gas lamp it's gonna blow we got to get
out of here it's gonna be something and
some have speculated too that there
might have actually been an explosion
now I will note that there's not any
there wasn't any obvious sign of an
explosion like down in the hold however
I think in the 2000s
um they actually did a like an
experiment where they showed that a
particular kind of explosion like
actually could just have kind of a flash
explosion that it wouldn't really leave
any singing or anything now I will note
that the uh that the particular
uh things that you need for that to
happen or the conditions are kind of
rare so it's not really certain if
that's what happened or not but that
might have been something that caused
some Panic maybe there was like an
explosion and they were just like oh
[__] the ship's blowing up it would have
been a very low pressure explosion right
not like a [__] high explosive where
it shattered wood
uh here's a good example I talked about
this on another show we were partying
one time in Mississippi where we're
spiking our own punch bowl with [__]
Everclear
Everclear in those days came
and hold on no I got it backwards we
took the Everclear and I had in those
days we had Hawaiian Punch and Hawaiian
Punch came in a can
a big can it's like two liter canned and
you could use a bottle opener basically
and put two triangle triangular holes in
it and pour the
Hawaiian Punch Out
and the bottom of the Hawaiian Punch
can
there was some Hawaiian Punch
and I poured some uh Everclear into it
and stirred it around and was drinking
it through from the uh from the triangle
and [__] when I put my nut and my
mouth up to it I said oh man smell that
dude's the Joey Joey's next to me I said
smell that man he goes damn you know he
smells just like alcohol coming up and
he grabbed his cigarette lighter and
[__] touched it to the top of that
triangular hole and it [__] lit up
and it thrusted like a rocket I felt the
whole can swell in my hand and get hot
and go and thrust thrust like two or
three seconds like a rocket engine
and then it would have burned out and it
just flashed out
like it had never happened
didn't didn't damage anything yeah maybe
that's what happened in that cargo hold
maybe a bunch of gas built up and
somebody went over there with a it was
night time and they went over there with
a Gas Lantern
and set it off
and maybe it blew a bunch of fire out
through a hatch
a cargo hatch and they saw that and it
scared the [__] out of him and they
Abandoned Ship I mean now the main hatch
was still closed okay and it was Secure
there was another hatch open but there
were two other hatches that were open
I'm not sure like where they were
located on the ship though maybe it just
the gas fumes just [__] touched off a
blue flame shot out of there and it
scared the [__] out of them they thought
the place was going to blow up even
though the gas had burned off
here's the thing though um and some you
know some researchers have pointed out
they're like the whole Lifeboat staying
Tethered to the main ship Theory they're
like if they legit thought that the ship
was going to blow up or sink you
wouldn't think that they would want to
remain Tethered to it
I believe maybe they're waiting to see I
believe that the rope that you know that
had the Lifeboat that was attaching was
cut
and not torn hmm
so maybe they thought it was blowing up
again or something right
so like I said whatever it was must have
been bad because they everything
happened like really quickly it seemed
like
um now so like I said it must have been
something like really alarming to get
like a seasoned captain and a seasoned
crew
to kind of panic essentially I don't you
know what I mean or at least like get
felt like they need to get off the ship
so um there was also remember how I said
that that kind of like ursat's sounding
Rod was found on the deck yeah
they thought maybe what happened was
that the sounding Rod uh wasn't working
right and it gave the captain a false
reading because like I said that's
supposed to tell you how much water is
in the hole there was only three and a
half feet in there there was too much
Cargo in the hold as far as I'm aware so
he wouldn't have been able to like
visually see how much water was in there
so if he took a sounding that was
incorrect maybe he thought the ship was
taking on more water than it actually
was and he thought it was sinking maybe
yeah
um so they could have been that as well
that would explain like that why the
sounding Rod was there why it was just
dropped on the deck like that because
they're like holy [__] there's all this
even though there wasn't like I said it
was only three and a half years which is
no big deal I only thought it was taking
on water and also one of the um one of
the pumps was also uh disassembled like
they had been trying to fix it
which they thought was interesting now
they said
um there was a thing too like prior to I
don't know when the disassembly took
place no no but like yeah all the pieces
were still there now they said prior to
Briggs captaining the ship because this
was his first voyage like on this ship
you know what I mean his first time
captaining it
um prior to that I believe it had been
carrying like a cargo of coal or
something like that and they're
speculating that maybe coal dust like
got in the pumps or something like that
and they were like taking it apart
because it was like clogged you know
that's another possibility
um there's also the possibility that
there was some kind of like weather
phenomenon that you know like a water
spout for example like because there was
like some water like in the ship or um
like a seaquake you know that might have
like or like a rogue wave something like
that
um you know but I kind of feel like it
was something it's more likely something
to do with that cargo yeah well I kind
of feel like if it was something like
you know a rogue wave I don't think it
was that because
it seemed like they had time at least to
like gather up a couple things and all
get in the Lifeboat and do the thing so
it must have been something that
happened that they could see coming like
I said so it could have been a water
spout they're like oh [__] that's gonna
but I kind of feel like if you're a
seasoned you know semen okay I said it
um if you've seen waterspouts before
I think that this is maybe a couple
things happening at once
under conditions that made them think
that a disaster was important right it
must have been that it must have been
that the [__] ship was either taking
water or getting ready to blow up
and you're like we got to get off the
ship
and they get off the ship maybe they're
maybe they're in that Lifeboat
and they're still Tethered to it
and maybe they're just waiting to see if
the ship goes down or if it blows up
and while they were waiting maybe
somebody just let go or untied it for
some reason yeah in a panic and the ship
never did go down and they stripped it
apart right couldn't catch up to the
ship and they couldn't yeah and that was
it they just maybe they didn't have any
oars with them so there was no way to
row
you know there's no way to know him or
the ship there was wind out that night
in the [__]
sales were still up and the [__] ship
accelerated away so they couldn't get
back to it they probably rode their
[__] asses off trying to catch it
never could get to it it was something
like that
there's something real
it was a misunderstanding
yeah I'm kind of thinking that's
probably what it was yeah now I was
reading like I said at the Smithsonian
Magazine they did a thing um like a good
article about it
they kind of um looked into weather
conditions at the time like the route
and everything like that they thought
that maybe the captain's uh chronometer
was faulty and that he was off course
without being aware of it and
um they thought that when the bad thing
happened he actually they were either
within sight of an island or he thought
that an island was close by so he
thought oh well This ship's gonna go
down so everybody get in here that's
that's land is just like right over
there and it wasn't yeah you know what I
mean somebody was asking about a Riptide
Riptides usually happen up near the up
near the coast like near where the
beaches are yeah not so much
ocean what it was is they got off the
ship
and they were Tethered to it
and somehow they became untethered and
they couldn't catch back up to the ship
wind was out and the sails were up
and it accelerated away they couldn't
roll back up to it to catch up with it
and the question is is why they why they
abandoned ship
they thought it was going to sink they
thought it was either taking water or
they thought it was going to blow up
or the foot they smelled a bunch of
[__] alcohol and smelled gases maybe
they thought they'd suffocate so maybe
they thought maybe if we distance
ourselves from the ship and hold on to
it to a line we'll let it all air out
and then yeah and then we'll go back but
somehow they lost they got separated
they got separated they couldn't catch
up it was something like that yeah
because it looks like they definitely
left deliberately and in something of a
hurry so it must have been some kind of
like I said alarming scenario the
alarming smell we need to get off this
ship yeah it was a cup it was a couple
things that happened that were out of
their control
maybe they smelled this gases and they
thought it was going to kill them so
they got to get off the ship
and they said well we'll just hold on to
it with a line
when the [__] ship airs out we'll get
back in but then they got separated and
they couldn't catch up to the ship
and then they didn't make it at sea
you know they had all their navigational
stuff but
they were out in the middle of nowhere
they never made it back they were never
found
yeah they never found out they never
found any of them yeah which meant that
they die to thirst
means they were dead within about a week
which is scary what if ooh what if they
were out there floating in that [__]
life about they probably I'm sure they
were a branded Lifeboat for about that's
horrifying and it's like I said you have
to think too there's like there's a baby
which was two years old baby wouldn't
have made it maybe wouldn't have made it
three or four days bro yeah two years
old little girl yeah that was the
captain's daughter they dehydrate quick
but yeah so
um
so there had been some cases like I said
where you know ships that had cargo of
alcohol had exploded before and it
should be noted too that I believe in
the ship's log which has since been lost
um they do know what the last few days
of it said because uh good old Sally
flood the the pump the Papa's ass
um he actually copied down
uh a lot of the last uh stuff you know
for the for the trial or the hearing or
whatever so that's kind of the only
surviving record of it and apparently
there had been weird noises like coming
from the hold like Rumblings and stuff
like that so maybe they were kind of
over the few days were worried that it
was going to blow up also talked about
like
um some kind of some real rough weather
so it could have been a combination of
those two things I feel like so there
was evidence of not only that they were
worried about some kind of weird noise
in the hold but also like the weather
had been bad never found they never
found the logs that was all lost on the
damn light boat it probably was in the
logs no they found the logs they found a
log yeah because they they found them on
this they were still on the ship okay it
was just the captain's papers that were
yeah he took like the papers did the
logs mention anything
that's what I just said it did
no I just said that the ship that the
log mentioned that there had been like
rumbling noises coming from the hold oh
and then how long did that go on for I
don't like a few days and then also
um that there that the weather had been
really really bad like
weather probably uh some of those
alcohol barrels were became dislodged
from the rough rough weather and we're
rolling around
maybe and like I said three of them are
uh eight or nine of them had
were empty so the stuff had like seeped
out seeped out or but they hadn't been
opened no
but like I said they were made of a
different kind of wood than the other
barrels uh which was more porous
so it probably just seeped out
the fact that they were empty I think
was one of the things that made flood
think that they had drank the stuff and
like went crazy but that wasn't the case
it probably just seeped out
because it was a different kind of win
and it went down into the bilge water
yeah because there was some water down
there did it smell like alcohol I wonder
don't know
but that well like I said still
evaporate and go into the hold
yeah I don't even smell and would you
smell all of it I mean I think they
smelled something
they thought it was gonna they heard
something rumbling they must have been
must have been kind of spooked that
something's going wrong in the cargo
hold
yeah
but you think they'd go down in there
and check
oh it's weird
maybe it wasn't that at all something
else happened they thought the ship was
on fire or they
thought it was going to blow up I think
it thought it was going to blow up it's
only explanation
yeah that's the only thing that would
like cause sufficient alarm but it'd be
like holy [__] we need to get off here
like right now yeah it was something
that they thought they had to get off
right then to something that they
couldn't fix
I think I can think of what they thought
it was gonna blow up yeah
but it didn't yeah that's what's kind of
sad about it but uh but yeah so as I
said um they actually did do an
experiment in 2006 but you know kind of
exploring the uh explosion Theory to see
if there could have been an expl like an
actual explosion on the ship without
there have been any evidence of it and
uh yeah they did under certain
conditions uh that absolutely can't
happen
you can have an explosion without any
particular uh fire damage or scorching
or anything like that so you know that
it's so it's possible the they thought
it was going to explode or it did
explode especially the alcohol fumes
I've seen it right I was holding a damn
alcohol rocket for a few seconds and
when it was over it's like it never
happened
now very low pressure yeah and it's not
that hot
Ben said they might have been doing an
evacuation drill and all gotten into the
Long Boat and falling into the sea 1800s
wasn't much for training in [__]
drills and [__] I don't think
just suck it up you'll figure it out
yeah that's like I feel like yeah
nowadays it's like you practice in case
something goes wrong but back then back
and then think that way you just kind of
wing it they didn't have any concept of
safety they couldn't even put a railing
around [__] huge gears
yeah you know we could put a guard over
this to keep these kids from falling
into that big ass gear but they're just
kids you know that's okay there's lots
of other ones yeah we've got more of
them
it's sad but true they were people were
just uh victorians didn't have weren't
safety minded weren't safety conscious
they just weren't yeah they didn't think
that way yeah they didn't really think
about it yeah Carly said most of the
sailors could not swim I've heard that
actually
you'd think that that would be the first
thing you'd want to learn how to do if
you're going to spend your life on the
ocean but I think they're kind of forced
into that life as shown on short notice
I think a lot of times poverty made him
become Sailors a lot of guys got
shanghaied into it and [__] true
goes to the serial killer on board maybe
yeah I doubt it I think there would be
more evidence of that I think it was
some kind of no it was it was a natural
disaster it was like some kind of
accident on the ship where they felt
like they had to get off now
interestingly explanation like I said
um a lot of details that people remember
because like Trey was saying that was in
those weird like Unsolved Mysteries
books or whatever
um a lot of details got added later on
uh for example in 1883
you know uh years after the incident the
LA Times Like reprinted the story but
added some uh creepier sounding details
like um all the sales were set not true
uh the tiller was lashed fast not a rope
was out of place also not true um you
know the ropes were kind of hanging all
over the place and sort of raggedy uh
the fire was burning in the galley the
dinner was standing untasted and
scarcely cold the log written up to the
hour of her Discovery none of this stuff
was true
um there was no dinner on the table like
I said there was no fire burning in the
thing and the log uh was only recent up
to nine days prior to the ship being
found I believe the last entry was at 5
00 am uh nine days prior to Jeff ER
found the guy that I was talking about
who was mummified
Manfred Fritz bajorat bajorat yeah Mama
fighting his boat in 2016. I think it
was missing for three years three years
okay yeah I remember kind of hearing
about that but yeah I saw photographs
yeah well it's that's pretty crazy it's
kind of slightly green I'm gonna have to
well yeah
I mean I mean a little bit of floating
around in the ocean dead for three years
you're not gonna look your best either
so yeah he had mold growing on him
correctly yeah
well that yeah that makes sense yeah
what do you have like Barnacles on them
and no it's just mold
with Barnacles they're gonna try that
mold on him yikes
imagine being
famous for that for being the mummified
and the boat guy yeah oh well I guess he
doesn't know any different but yeah so a
lot of the stuff was um you know the
stuff about the dinner and the ship
being like completely pristine and
intact uh not true but a lot of that was
added only like probably eight nine ten
years after the fact like when everybody
started like embellishing the story as
it does because it's like a better story
like that it's creepier
um and as I mentioned in 1884
uh Sir Arthur Conan Doyle who I don't
think he was like super super famous at
this time he was still fairly young but
he wrote a short story
um he was a ship surgeon at the time and
it was called Jay habakkuk Jefferson's
statement and it was essentially a
retelling well the ship was called the
Marie Celeste like with an ie instead of
a y and it was purported to be it was
told in the first person and it was like
it was like um someone that was on the
ship like telling what had happened now
in the short story
um which took place in 1873. uh the ship
was actually going from Boston to Lisbon
which uh is actually not the case it was
actually in real life was going from New
York City to Genoa
um and in this in the story it had
passengers on it
and it turned out that what happened to
the crew in the short story was that um
a guy who I think it was an escaped
slave named Septimus uh hated white
people and so slaughtered all of them I
was like okay yeah how do you get out
there in the ocean I don't really know I
guess he worked on the ship or something
like that so he was like he murdered
like the captain or something he's gonna
take he would like uh was commandeering
the ship and he was going to take it to
Africa or something like that yeah
um also back to Africa movement yeah I
guess but then there was like a magical
charm involved too so you know what I
mean
um
but uh yeah it was crazy but that's the
thing I kind of feel like even though he
just wrote the story like as a lark and
it was just very Loosely based on the
Mary Celeste thing some of the details
from that got conflated with the real
story as well
uh also because this was a very popular
story in 1913 uh uh the Strand magazine
also published another account which was
purportedly True by somebody which uh
who survived it
um even though the dude's name and he
was supposedly a steward on there like
we didn't have a steward and we didn't
have anybody by that name on the ship
but okay so people were just making [__]
up like back then just to get their five
minutes of fame I guess
um and there his tail like what happened
to everybody was that all of the crew
were
um they were having a swimming contest
and they had this platform set up and it
collapsed and everybody fell in the
ocean and drowned or got eaten by sharks
except for him so he was around to like
tell the tale so I was like okay
but you know they changed a lot of
details for that as well
uh so yeah so there were a couple of
other ones later on like throughout the
early 20th century adding all kinds of
details so that's where a lot of the
kind of creepier aspects of the story
came from they came from like
fictionalized stories and [__] like that
now interestingly even though the crew
disappeared and have never been seen
again uh the ship itself
still uh they still used it like for a
while afterwards which like I said you'd
think it would be kind of creepy like
being on that [__] but um so it drops
eye on the ship well they'd be there
yeah that's true they didn't die yeah I
guess it would be like creepier if you
would because to be honest it's pretty
creepy like getting on there like just
finding nobody but I don't know it'd
probably be worse to get on there and
like find a bunch of like dead bodies
yeah so you know what I mean they just
never found the people they left yeah
and got separated so after the Mary
Celeste like dropped off the alcohol in
Genoa
um and it went back to sail back to New
York and because of all of the hearings
and all this stuff um you know the ship
was actually quite famous now so uh
nobody really wanted it like anymore
because of all of this you know creepy
[__] that was associated with it so it
got sold in 1874.
uh at a very large loss because like I
said no one really wanted it
um yeah because it's like bad luck
because like I said this is like the
third captain now like to die I think
um so a bunch of like New York business
guys like uh owned it and then they kind
of used it as a trade ship like uh West
Indies Indian Ocean stuff like that um
pretty much operating as a at a loss
like uh for the entire time they didn't
make any money on it because like I said
it was you know people say I've saw it
it's kind of like cursed or whatever
um actually they had another captain
a guy named Edgar Tuthill uh in 1879 and
he actually
um died also like just he got off the
ship because he was like not feeling too
good and uh he died too so yeah a lot of
people were kind of like cursed it's
cursed you know what I mean so yeah
that's that was the third captain that
died uh prematurely
so uh at that point they sold the ship
to another you know Consortium of dudes
this guy this a bunch of dudes from
Boston
and they had a new captain installed
whose name was Thomas Fleming uh you
know not a weird name there and he
stayed on there until uh 1884 and then
he got replaced with another dude named
Gilman Parker no relation to nutting
Parker I'm imagining
um and then it just kind of like changed
hands a bunch of times uh you know with
probably nothing weird happening uh like
I said just operating as a loss most of
the time now in 1884 this Parker dude I
guess because the ship wasn't making any
money and I guess it was kind of you
know notorious and everything like that
he decided I'm gonna pull some insurance
fraud
so he put a bunch of worthless [__] onto
the ship
and then wrote in the manifest like on
the ship that it was a bunch of valuable
[__]
and then he went to uh Port-au-Prince in
Haiti and he basically like um ran it
into a coral reef on purpose damn
so um it's just which ripped out the
whole entire bottom of the ship
so then him and the crew like rode
themselves to shore oh my God we're
alive that was like that was terrible
and then he ended up selling the cargo
uh to the American console for 500 and
then he filed an insurance claim
however
um an investigation ensued uh at which
point they discovered that all of the
cargo was useless and that he had run
the ship aground on purpose so the dude
got arrested
um for what they called willfully
casting away the ship uh this at this
crime actually had a name uh called
baratry
and uh the punishment for baritry at
that time was death damn
so um so yeah they're like they executed
no okay they were well yeah but that I
mean that was the punishment usually
because they didn't [__] around I guess
like you do this you pull this [__] with
the ship and he didn't even kill anybody
Jesus Christ but yeah
um
so basically they the jury couldn't
agree on a verdict
and um basically they're like he there
was another charge like he was for
conspiracy or something like that and
then the judge basically was like you
know they they negotiated some [__]
they're like well we won't kill you as
long as you pay back all of the money
that you stole essentially like um I
wonder if he was able to do that
um probably not yeah I well I think he
died only a couple years later yeah I
got away with it like he did it though
because like he died like penniless yeah
like only a few months after like after
he was released and actually like one of
the other guys that was in on it too
like went crazy and was like went in an
asylum and then the other one like
killed himself so you know what I mean
it didn't end well for anybody
um which again that only like fed into
the Mary Celeste like curse yeah thing
because holy [__]
now interestingly uh so yeah so after
that the ship um was pretty much uh done
for
and they just kind of wrecked it or just
grabbed it yeah now in August it was a
wooden ship or a steel ship it wouldn't
wouldn't okay yeah it was wooden
um in August of 2001
uh Clive Cussler who you may know as a
hugely famous author and he's also a
marine archaeologist
he wanted to do an expedition to see if
he could find the remains of the Mary
Celeste and
um they found like some metal shed and
like some pieces of Timber and stuff
like that
um which kind of was where the Marie
Celeste supposedly
sunk you know what I mean
um and they're like well it looks like
the wood that like when they did all the
tests on it said it looks like the wood
that they would have used like when the
Mary Celeste was refitted like in 1872
so they're like oh we found it but then
they did
um dendrological tests which you know
the tree ring [__]
and um they found out that the wood on
this ship came from trees which had not
been cut down until after the Mary
Celeste would have been built so they're
like okay so that wasn't that so as far
as I know they haven't really found the
remains of it they thought they did but
they didn't
so um as I mentioned this has been a
very famous story over the years uh
there's been plays and movies and all
kind of like stuff there was a hammer
movie in 1935 called The Mystery of the
Mary Celeste
um in the US it's called Phantom ship
actually 35 1935 yeah and Bella Lugosi
yeah was in it oh man maybe we should
see it I kind of felt like that too I
was like yeah we totally should see that
and then there was also another short
movie in uh 1938 called the ship that
died
um that has that's more like a
documentary type thing which kind of has
a bunch of different theories presented
like it has like some Supernatural ones
like oh it was a giant well a giant
squid isn't Supernatural but you know
what I mean like a sea monster or like
ghosts or Kraken or yeah a kraken or
something like that because that's one
that I didn't mention but that's one
that a lot of I'm like you'd think that
there would be more you think the
character would [__] that [__] up yeah
the ship would be all [__] up what
like the crack in his little tentacles
just come up he's like I'm just gonna
take all the crew members and and the
chronometer and the Sextant yeah and the
Lifeboat and that's it
[Laughter]
yeah
uh but yeah okay
are you back there poking yeah right
there oh so as I mentioned uh
Smithsonian channel did like a
documentary about it and I read like the
article that came out in conjunction
with it where they pretty much thought
that um what happened was that uh there
was some kind of pump congestion or
something like that because of the coal
remember because I said that um it had
transported coal prior and the pump was
disassembled uh on the deck and uh so
they didn't and also the sounding Rod
there and they're like they maybe
thought the ship was sinking because
they couldn't tell how much how much
water was in the hold and maybe that
caused them to like panic and all get
off the ship but most people that
you know that subscribe to realistic
theories
um obviously
something went wrong on the ship that
was Dire enough for seasoned
cap for a seasoned sea captain to be
like we need to get off this boat
like he thought that it would be safer
either getting in the Lifeboat and like
Towing behind like for a little while or
sailing for land which was supposedly
nearby so I so I don't really buy the
murder thing I don't buy the pirate
thing there's just like not evidence of
it like not impossible but I kind of
feel like it just looks like they left
in a hurry but not there did there
wasn't any violence there wasn't
anything like that so it was just
something bad happened they thought this
shit's going down let's get the [__] off
here and then they just didn't make it
yeah
and so I think that's probably all this
but it's still creepy it's still a
creepy story and nobody knows and
probably no one will ever know exactly
what happened they never found their
bodies nothing like that it was a series
of events that led them to incorrect
[__] conclusions in each event and it
led them down a path that they didn't
return from that's they thought they
were doing the right thing but they work
but they yeah but they didn't know that
they didn't know that I mean if they had
just stayed on the ship they would have
been final right yeah but it must have
been something really bad that it's like
we can't stay on the ship we don't know
the exact conditions right Abandoned
Ship under there might have been a storm
happening at the time it may have been a
night storm and they may not been able
to check the actual condition of the
ship and
because they did say that the weather
had been rough like for the last few
days and it could have been that
somebody yelled something from across
the ship and it would and it was
misinterpreted what the person said and
he says he said Abandoned Ship we got to
go you know that kind of [__] yeah
and then the dude who said who did not
say abandon ship that's what they
thought that he said is seeing everybody
abandoned his ship he goes oh [__]
abandonment
all right yeah yeah they don't know why
it could have been something just that
simple
yeah I was gonna say I think I forgot to
mention like when I was talking about
the murder theories
that one of the murder theories was that
two of the guys on the crew of the Mary
Celeste were these two German brothers
and uh for a while like some people
suspected they had killed all the crew
because their [__] was not on the ship
like all like their belongings so they
thought oh well they killed everybody
and then took their [__] and skedaddled
and then they just like went and like
the witness protection program somewhere
or something like that but then it came
out later on that their [__] wasn't on
the boat because the ship that they had
been on prior um they'd been in a
shipwreck so they actually didn't have
any [__] you know what I mean looking
back at some of the [__] accidents
and [__] that are happened in our units
[__] when we were in the Army back in
the Infantry a lot of this [__]
most of it had to do with the conditions
people not hadn't
you know hadn't been sleeping for days
on end
um it happened at night the [__]
so you can't really see
um it's cold as [__] so people are kind
of
stupid you know uh cold will make you
real slow and stupid and make you not
want to do things like ah I don't want
to pick that up I'm too cold you know
that kind of [__] you know
um it was the conditions I think that
contributed to this some kind of
confusion happened and they thought they
had to get off the ship and they they
weren't really A sound mind maybe they
woke maybe there's a real bad storm
a lot of them were sick or
um
they haven't been able to sleep and it
was night time and they were exhausted
and they were just sick of the [__] and
some people have speculated too that
maybe the alcohol fuse made them kind of
loopy maybe something yeah maybe they
smelled alcohol fumes and they thought
oh man like so that might have
contributed too maybe they thought all
the [__] maybe all the alcohol
canisters had [__] broken loose and
they were all broken and all the [__]
all that fluid was just loose in the
cargo hold and they're like oh man that
shit's gonna catch on fire let's get the
[__] out of here you know
it was something like that and they
weren't really of totally sound mind
maybe they got maybe they woke up out of
a maybe they were just
maybe they all woke up
um out of a deep sleep or something and
didn't have much notice you know there
might have been half asleep when they're
making these decisions there's no way of
knowing there's something having to do
with the conditions yeah I mean they're
out in the middle of the [__] ocean
all kind of terrible things can happen
I'm fair I have a feeling it happened at
night
well like I said the electricity the
last log entry was at 5 a.m but there
didn't appear to be anything wrong then
but it does seem like whatever happened
like happened not too long after that
maybe yeah I'm thinking that it's
probably happened at night it's before
electricity
so that means the ship isn't really well
lit
something happens and they can't really
see to verify if the damage really
happened like are we taking water yeah
we might be taking water but I can't see
they didn't have electric flashlights
back then
you know yeah everything was a pain in
the ass back then you couldn't see [__]
yeah
just take your cell phone out of your
pocket I think it's taking water he's
looking down in the hole you know and he
said I ain't going down there it's dark
and it was something like that
and then he said well we'll get out of
here and we'll just trail behind the
ship and just hold the line hold the
line if the ship goes down let go that's
that kind of [__] either that or they
thought that there was land nearby yeah
near enough
I don't know I don't think that I think
they got out they wouldn't have counted
on that well what I read I read that
where they were whenever this [__]
happened
um they probably would have been able to
see Santa Maria Island like they weren't
that far away from it maybe they did see
it so maybe they saw so they so maybe
they weren't even gonna stay attached to
the ship maybe they said we're gonna go
to Santa Maria Island and then they
didn't make it and then they didn't make
it for some reason maybe yeah you know I
so that could be a possibility also I'm
pretty sure like I read that somewhere
that they would have been able to see it
probably could have been their trailing
behind it and they're holding onto the
Rope
and they probably have instructions well
if the ship starts going down just let
go of the Rope we don't want to go down
with it
and then Augusta wind came and pulled on
that ship hard and it accelerated away
they were too weak they couldn't hold it
and it [__] pulled the Rope out of
their hand
and that was it then they could catch up
with the chef It's just sad it's sad I
mean they didn't they didn't know but
it's like had they stayed on the ship
they probably would have been fine you
know like the [__] would have passed and
they'd be like oh everything's fine and
they just would have got to Genoa and
lived out the rest of their lives Tammy
said maybe it was aliens Yeah well yeah
some people have said alien objection no
mistake misadventure Misadventures
that's one way I'm putting it yeah but
yeah it's a sad story it's just really
exciting yeah and they were probably out
there for about a week down to thirst
that's what I was thinking I was
thinking oh man it's like if they I mean
unless they drowned right away it's like
they were probably just out there
floating around in the [__] Atlanta
they were in that [__] thing floating
around in a direct sunlight which is
yeah with limited water
hey I've seen I've seen that [__] on I
shouldn't be alive and those bodies were
those bodies were in that [__] boat
for [__] months exposed to the sun
and the rain
Birds [__] yeah like eating their
eyeballs out and [__] yeah so it was
just in the end the ocean man it was
just a [__] it's no fun life it was
just a Lifeboat with [__] skeletons
and rags
imagine coming across that when you're
in the middle of the Atlantic usually
they die you know they die one by one
and a lot of times they throw them out
throw them out the boat throw the baby
out and [__] so maybe there would be
nobody in there except one person the
last one
you know I've been there with a stinky
ass dead body in the direct sunlights
they throw them out usually
well yeah because sharks they'll eat
them oh they don't like you yeah you
don't want to keep sharks around the
[__] well you don't want to be in
that [__] boat with a dead stinking
dead body they throw it out
well yeah that's true
didn't we see that I shouldn't be a live
episode where like somebody died in the
ship and then they're like just left
they left him in there yeah like for a
few days and they were like there's
[__] corpse juice in the bottom of
the [__] boat and I was like gross
they get desperate they [__] die in a
thirst and they reach down and they
start drinking salt water and that
[__] makes it even worse and they go
crazy I mean I I get it like if you're
desperate enough you're just like just
[__] it I just even though you know
you're not supposed to drink salt water
usually by the time they drink salt
water they're already dying that's what
I'm saying
so then they're already half crazy and
then they drink the salt water and uh
they feel better for a few seconds and
they start hallucinating and they do
things like I forgot my car keys and
they jump out and start swimming
we saw that that happened like on that
one like I said we saw this um wasn't I
shouldn't be alive or it was one a show
like that and yeah it was like a bunch
of friends and there were ships saying
and um they were all in a Lifeboat and
yeah that happened like the dude started
like drinking I think he did drink salt
water didn't he and he started going
crazy yeah he said I forgot my car I
forgot my car keys and he just jumped in
the [__] ocean yeah and started to
start swimming and the Sharks got him
sharks were waiting yeah the sharks they
said they saw the Sharks just eating him
on the surface I can't imagine that's
got to be like one of the [__] worst
things ever you would never be able to
like unsee that sharks were waiting
because they were in a rubber life raft
and the Sharks could smell them through
this yeah
rubber life raft and [__] lubber rifles
they were just saying [__] it they were
so weak they were just pissing in the
bottom of the [__] rubber life raft
and then they'd get desperate reached
out in there and they had blood and pus
coming out of their [__] sores and
their legs and it never
never that's what I mean I'm just like
[__] that [__] nope I'm not even going
on a cruise ship or nothing no thank you
nope I don't I don't want to be on an
episode of that show I'll [__] ride
around you know my my dad was in the
Navy he was on the USS Yorktown
the raised Yorktown and uh they
modernized it he's in the South China
Sea during the Vietnam campaign he was
electrician
and [__]
got guts man to be on the foot be an ex
infantry I'll ride around [__] hell
choppers with the [__] doors open and
[__] you're not getting me on that water
no way I don't blame you gonna have the
[__] ground you can get me in the sky
and on the ground not on the water I got
a lot of respect for [__] those dudes
you know yeah mostly it's a cush job but
when it goes bad it goes really bad
yeah and you just thought I don't want
to drown and I don't want to [__] die
in a [__] Lifeboat I don't want to be
eaten by sharks
it's floating you know that's the those
are like yeah that's the worst like a
doll's eye yeah I can't you know I can't
really think of anything scarier than
that just like knowing that you're
getting eaten getting eaten by yeah you
out there to Cluster dudes floating in
the water one by one being eaten by
sharks that's like one of the worst
things seriously that story just like
that well I used to have nightmares like
that when I was a kid like Ugh being on
the ocean is very akin to being in outer
space yeah it might as well it might as
well be in outer space yeah you can
breathe that's the only difference
but you there's water water everywhere
and not a drop to drink
and there's like a whole bunch of really
big creatures swimming around there
where you can't see them and they would
really really like to snack on you so
yeah oh thank you no thank you sir Madam
so you want to shut it down yeah better
because it's getting to be it's almost
bedtime oh [__] I've been looking
forward to that what
well now I gotta take a shower and go to
sleep because I gotta get up as early in
the morning
um but yeah so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this show about the Mary Celeste
I had a good time doing this show this
was like a fun topic well it's not fun
but it's kind of depressing but it's
it's a good show yeah I I found it like
really entertaining Sammy said you would
be praying for aliens in that Lifeboat
yeah it's like now the aliens can come
yeah please save me you can even anal
probe me if you want but um
how dare you but
[Laughter]
like this
he was so indignant that movie man that
[__] movie I can't understand it I
don't either I could not understand that
I don't wear a [__] movie that was
called community
what the [__] were they thinking that
that I really don't know I heard that
book is is quite it is quite [__]
wild but it's pretty crazy I read it a
long time ago make a movie based on that
that's like I had to put Christopher
Walken in it of all people yeah I mean
and it really wasn't a horror movie it's
not no it was just
I'm not really sure what kind of movie
it is
it's just like a [__] Oddity glad
that I did not see that under the
influence of LSD
I'd have been very disturbed
Ben said that book was a blockbuster so
they had to make a movie of it yeah yeah
it was everybody was talking about that
[__] I think there was even like
commercials for it on TV like back in
the 80s I remember it was that in the
commercials
oh yeah maybe it was the 90s I think I
can't remember when it came out but yeah
all right so uh I guess we're gonna shut
it down so I can go to sleep and get up
at five in the morning uh but yeah so
hopefully you guys enjoyed the show
um we're taking the day off tomorrow but
we'll be back on Friday evening uh for
the side track show probably
um are you gonna want to go to
mannequins Friday night well we'll see
probably we'll see because they're
they're they're instituting their new
thing yeah we'll go we'll go so uh so
maybe we'll go we'll do that so we'll do
some like pre-gaming and uh talk to you
guys so uh yeah hopefully we'll see you
guys again on Friday evening and thanks
for dropping by remember to like and
share and comment and all that kind of
stuff and we'll see you guys again on
Friday night bye